i began my sex work journey
in 2014 going on sugar daddy dates for
money
i was then later forced into a full
service sex work
by someone i loved i felt empowered when
i had a choice
but when i had no choice out of
financial desperation and the fact i was
told i didn't have a choice
i began to lose the ability to feel
human by the end of it
jessica was raped multiple times she has
post-traumatic stress disorder
partly a result of enforced sex work she
says
she was desperate for money i went to
several
mental health institutions for support
and they turned me away because i was a
sex worker even though i begged them to
help me stop
i had no family to help me
i was just completely alone with it and
struggling
so much i remember there was one time
where
there was a glass of water in front of
me and i couldn't get up to get the
water
and like i was getting turned away by
the end of it because
i was just i couldn't i couldn't do it i
wasn't up to the job
and the last time i did sex work ever
i cried in the middle of it and um he
let me keep the money and go home
and you worried other people will feel
the same as you did i don't ever want
anyone to feel like i did
i know i don't i i would be there for
anybody that came to me to stop
them feeling like i did and that's why
she set up what is currently the
country's
only student sex worker support group
based in manchester
and helping people throughout the
pandemic for me
it's not just about helping the whole
community it's about the individual
i think if you can make a difference in
one individual's life
and you've made all the difference in
the world there's been an overall
increase in sex work altogether
people have been let girlfriend in their
jobs temporarily and permanently
and universal credit doesn't pay enough
for people to live on
which is a it's a positive thing because
in the sector
sex work is becoming more and more
accepted as a job but
it presents its risks the need for
organizations like
jessica's support for student sex
workers is growing
sky news has learned that a rising
number of university students
are turning to sex work as a result of
kovid 19
and its economic impact figures from a
survey by save the student show that 10
percent would consider sex work in a
financial emergency
nearly double the number compared to
last year while in a separate survey
seven percent of students say they've
actually turned to sex or
adult work during the pandemic as a way
of plugging the gap in a cash crisis
seventy-seven percent were female 22
percent male
initially it was only lingerie i did
that for the first two months and then i
decided to go topless
so do you have a line nothing below the
waist rose will graduate from
university next year she turned to sex
work online
because the restaurant she worked in
closed down due to the pandemic
we've revoiced her words to protect her
identity
so if you weren't doing it where do you
think you'd be financially i'd be
struggling
even though i live with family i don't
like to live there for free i like to
pay my keep
i'm not doing anything that obscene and
i'm not meeting people in real life
i'm just acting and modelling and i'm
earning money that i can eventually buy
a house with
she now earns hundreds of pounds
sometimes nearly 2 000 a month
through a subscription website called
only fans
so you find it liberating very very
liberating
i'm in control of my own content i'm in
control of my own body
and i can do whatever i want with it
because you can set your own levels
do you feel safe doing it most of the
time
i'm not gonna lie and be oblivious that
someone could you know figure out who i
am and come up to me in the street
some websites aren't encrypted so your
content isn't private
i've had something leaked onto a very
dark website once which did scare me
it honestly did make me feel a bit
unsure and unsafe and not sure if i
should just quit there and then
but i decided not to hospitality and
retail have been hit hard
with thousands of jobs cut it means the
next 12 months for students could be
particularly fraught
there's no problem with people doing sex
work if it's something that they want to
do but if it's something they're being
forced to do
through an absolute lack of money then
that is something to be concerned about
we wouldn't be surprised to see that in
this year what we are expecting to be
one of the toughest years financially
for students for a very long time
to see that next year the number of
students who have actually done some
kind of sex work
to have jumped in some way there are now
calls for greater financial support for
students from the government
while some choose sex work because they
enjoy it
for others financial pressures may take
that choice away
for the extremely impoverished there
isn't always a choice
and it's those who feel forced who
become vulnerable
and at risk adele robinson sky news